keine guten nachrichten habe ich gerade
gesagt zwanzigster januar was wird an
diesem datum voraussichtlich passieren
kann ja kein du hast es angesprochen der
tunnel ist glaube ich noch länger
geworden und licht sieht man nirgendwo
mehr kann man sagen
tatsächlich ist es so dass wir du
sprichst von den hinterzimmern
tatsächlich ist es so dass es
verschiedene telefonschalten gegeben hat
in den vergangenen tagen erinnern uns
auch an die bilder von jens spahn mit
der kanzlerin nachts bis nach
mitternacht schon da hatte man so ein
gefühl da passiert gerade was jetzt
wissen wir aus mehreren quellen dass die
kanzlerin eine verschärfung des lok
downs möchte also wir wissen ja dass
bereits gesagt wurde sehr wahrscheinlich
wird der bisherige lockdown 31 der ja
ohnehin verlängert werden das war schon
so ein bisschen klar jetzt hören wir
aber dass es da um schärfere maßnahmen
geht und man fragt sich so ein bisschen
was kann man eigentlich noch überhaupt
noch genau
tatsächlich mit momentan darüber
diskutiert welche rolle der pnv und der
fernverkehr spielt es gibt überlegungen
sozusagen komplett diesen verkehr
einzustellen wir müssen dazu sehr
öffentliche personennahverkehr so nach
verkehren aber auch die fernzüge zum
beispiel wir müssen da zu sein dass es
noch nicht beschlossen worden das ist
diskussionsgrundlage
wir wissen aber aus dem
verkehrsministerium das bereits seit ein
paar tagen geprüft wird was das ganze
für konsequenzen in der logistikkette
hat und wie man sozusagen sicherstellen
kann
sollte das so entschieden werden dass
die lebensmittelversorgung funktioniert
wir erinnern uns daran im märz februar
da gab es diese sorge auch schon wir
kennen die bilder von den menschen die
dann das klopapier gehortet haben das
liegt in der produktionskette auch damit
zusammen was ist dann mit grenzen man
muss klar sagen der hintergrund für
schärfere maßnahmen also neben der
debatte um den verkehr
da gibt es eine debatte im kanzleramt
auch darüber was man mit homeoffice
verpflichtendes home office machen
könnte zum beispiel und die kanzlerin
hat in diesen runden immer wieder gesagt
das ist sind zu viele menschen auf der
straße zu viele menschen unterwegs
wir haben ja diese bilder noch im kopf
aus frankfurt zum beispiel aus der u
bahn
die bilder die ja auch der politische
diskussionen anschließend ausgelöst
haben wir auch gesagt habe
eigentlich habe so hart mensch da stehen
die leute dicht gedrängt und woanders
vor allen dingen der familie werden wir
gezwungen ganz strikt abstand zu halten
also das ist die reaktion ja offenbar
auch dann darauf hier sehen wir die
bilder gerade noch mal eine aus berlin
aus der u-bahn ich glaube in berlin ist
das duden hamburg absolut das sind die
bilder und die kanzlerin die ja wir
wissen in den vergangenen monaten ist
schon immer etwas schärfer wollte die
sagt dann in diesen sitzungen auch er
guckt euch das an doch an schaut euch
diese bilder an
ich kenne einen minister denen wir das
ganz plastisch beschrieben hat er dann
gesagt hat dann sagt die kanzlerin naja
aber es ist eben nicht so wie im
februar/märz deswegen müssen wir jetzt
mehr tun weil die leute weil die leute
eben nicht das so befolgen wie man es
erwartet hätte ein ganz wichtiger punkt
dabei und das ist der grund warum man
über verschärfungen überhaupt nachdenkt
auch einsatz der gefallen ist von einem
kontakte von einem minister und
ministerpräsidenten in dem fall die bis
herrscht die blanke angst vor den
mutationen das ist die es gibt einmal
die mutation in großbritannien es gibt
die südafrikanische mutation und das
problem dabei ist dass in dieser
mutierten variante es sich eben viel
mehr menschen anstecken und das
verrückte dabei ist muss man auch sagen
und das wird in politischen runden
gerade auch diskutiert wir wissen in
deutschland nicht mal wie weit sich
diese mutation ausgebreitet hat weil
anders als in anderen ländern wird das
nicht richtig geht alles langen der nur
einzelfälle bekannt hat ja auch gestern
ja uns zugeschaltet war der professor
gesagt bislang einzelfällen bundesländer
bekannt anfang weil und weil und das
sagt die kanzlerin auch in diesen
internen runden weil eben in ganz ganz
vielen fällen das gar nicht überprüft
wird welche variante so zu sagen wo sich
jemand angesteckt hat ich habe von einem
fall gehört hat heute erfahren
zufällig dass er die südafrikanische
variante hatte und jetzt sage ich mal
wenn ich das sozusagen zufällig von von
dem man höre ist die wahrscheinlichkeit
groß dass es da sehr sehr viele fälle
gibt und nicht diese zwölf oder was der
zuletzt genannt wurde
und das würde bedeuten wenn dieser
mutation hier ist dass das ganze dann
sich schnell ausbreiten das ist das noch
einmal ganz kurz zusammenfassen paul
weiß ja wie gesagt für unser aller
alltag so wichtig es du sagst es
herrscht die blanke panik die blanke
angst im moment hinter den kulissen in
der bundesregierung wegen
dieser mutationen des virus und man
beabsichtigt im kanzleramt im moment am
20 januar also weiter zu verschärfen vor
allen dingen den öffentlichen nahverkehr
drastisch einzuschränken und winter
dicht das ist auch ganz wichtiger punkt
schulen kitas weiter dicht man will
darauf drängen dass es mehr home office
gibt und man möchte den verkehr
sozusagen zurückfahren reisen
unterbinden damit die menschen sich
nicht mehr viel bewegt
wir sind bild und wir liefern dir deine
news auf youtube zum nächsten video
kommst du hier
und vergiss bitte nicht unseren kanal zu
abonnieren